next question from last time my mother
is 75 and I've tried to further explain
unity 2020
she doesn't understand dual governing
she keeps saying people don't work
together tips on what I can say
she'll be on board if she gets it it's a
classic yeah it is cool message look I
think people do work together I think
we're not used to seeing it because
we're used to seeing them in zero sum or
negative some dynamics which brings out
the worst in people
but if you set up a team and the idea is
the success condition looks like can you
figure out how to navigate together then
people don't want to find themselves in
failure condition what's more I mean
maybe this is the crux of the matter we
are so far away from policy that works
in the interests of most people that
doing better than we are doing is
actually easy right if all you did was
sweep away the corrupting influences
then figuring out what would be in the
interests of the American public is easy
at first there comes a point at which
you've done all the stuff that makes
sense right
and then you can have disagreements
about whether you want to prioritize
this value or that value but until you
get to all the basic stuff that needs to
just work then there's no point in
arguing right good people who have heard
the various inputs to the
decision-making process will be able to
reach agreement they may not nail it
right they may pick a second best
healthcare solution rather than the
absolute best one because it's
impossible to know enough to get it
exactly right but the point is a second
best healthcare solution would be about
a billion times better than the cruddy
one we have now so the point is yeah
let's get to one of the good ones and
then we can argue about whether or not
we got it exactly right and then we can
you know fight about ideology but at the
moment the ideology is hey let's have
some policy that serves us because I
thought it's supposed to do next one has
a comment says Unity 2020 is politically
naive it would elect a wet centrist and
change nothing as a founding member of
the first against the wall' Club I say
Brett should run or we kick him out of
the club it's all very kind are you
trying to get me killed no it's not it's
not about centrist the
I'm gonna say this very clearly because
I think this is important first of all I
have no patience with centrist and I am
very frequently the person challenging
the whole idea of centrism because I
think it's absurd however the center is
where we meet all right the Patriotic
center is where we meet to talk about
the immediate interests of the nation
right we can you know if you're on a
ship and it is sinking because it is
taking on water then the point is you
put aside your differences about ship
design and you deal with the question of
how do we get the water to leave the
ship faster than its coming in right
that's what the center looks like it
doesn't mean that the people involved in
the bilge mechanism don't have an idea
about how you might construct a ship
that would prevent this from happening
in the future they might but in the
meantime the ship is taking on water
everybody grab a bucket and let's deal
with the immediate problem right by
putting aside our ideological
differences which frankly if we talk
about them now they're gonna get us
killed how does Unity 2020 hope to deal
with Congress but you think there will
Stonewall you especially since both
sides well hey you have any plans to put
up candidates for Congress that last
question is one we haven't heard before
so you have said we're not gonna go into
details because we don't want them to
see us coming well some level let's put
it this way we can talk about the
Congress issue first of all there are a
lot of in every place in the system you
have people who are going to operate
according to the corrupt modality of the
system because frankly it's the smart
thing to do right you can starve
yourself by not participating you can be
a jerk and you can be corrupt no matter
what or you can function according to
the rules of the system as you find them
and hope for better rules and so some
fraction of the Congress is going to be
people who would love to be freed but
here's the thing
for unity 2020 to work we need a
groundswell sufficient to draft these
candidates that groundswell is a
credible threat against people whose
Stonewall in the Congress in other words
the reason that this can succeed is that
people are livid at how they are being
treated by their government to the
extent that you have people you
Congress who find themselves faced with
a presidential team that has been
elected specifically to drain the swamp
there is an incentive to declare
yourself not of the swamp to take a
pledge perhaps that would prevent you
from participating in swamp like
behavior and I believe there are many
ways that this could function so it's
not it's not a small issue but let's
just say the groundswell that tells the
apparatus that we are completely sick of
being treated this way and being
parasitized is the key not only to
changing the people in the White House
but to changing the Congress
[Music]